السلام عليكم قال مسؤولون من دوله جنوب
السودان انه لا مجال للحديث في هذه
المرحله عن عوده للوحده مع الشمال جاءت
هذه التصريحات عقب خطاب الرئيس السوداني
تحدث فيه عن جهات طلبت العوده لخيار
الوحده نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ماذا وراء هذه التصريحات المتضاربه
حول قضيه
الوحده وما هو السياق السوداني العام الذي
جاءت
فيه فجاه عادت الى الواجهه طروحات تتحدث
عن خيار الوحده بين دول وتي السودان وجنوب
السودان فبعد خطاب للرئيس عمر البشير اشار
الى هذا الاحتمال جاء نفي على لسان اكثر
من مسؤول احدثهم السكرتير الاعلامي لرئيس
جنوب السودان نتابع اولا ما قاله بالضبط
مع تذكير بما قاله الرئيس السوداني قبل
يومين في ناس ساعدونا لكن الشعب بتاع
الجنوب هم اللي غرروا بالنسبه ل 99% ده
شعب بتاع الجنوب زول
اكبر شعب بتاع الجنوب ما في زول بيقدر
يعمل قرار انه يرجع جنوب السودان لسودان
ولا الشعب بتاع جنوب السودان هم انفسهم
كما هم
يعني صوت على انفال جنوب السودان هم ممكن
يقرروا لو عايزين يخلوا هويه ب جنوب
السودان ت ما بتجي من السياسيين ما
السياسيين بقولوا
كده فصل الجنوب ده عشان يدمر الشمال ماله
اي سب
تاني حصل يا
جماعه هسه كلهم بيجوا والله يا جماعه احنا
كنا غلطانين ما سمعنا كلامكم احنا ندمانين
لا احنا ما
ندمانين قالوا تعالوا توحد قلتله والله
كده احنا دوله قائمه عشان جزء اني انضم
لنا لازم نست الشعب
السوداني المره دي لو في توحد الشعب
السودان يقول لي رايك شنو ده اذا احنا
اقتنعنا معنا في هذه الحلقه من الخرطوم
كمال حسن علي وزير الدوله لشؤون الرعايه
الاجتماعيه والدكتور خالد التجاني رئيس
تحرير صحيفه الافه السودانيه ومن جب مارتن
ايليا وزير شؤون الرئاسه في دوله جنوب
السودان اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا بالسيد
كمال حسن علي ما الذي اعاد هذا الحديث في
موضوع ظل ظن الجميع انه اغلق
وانتهى طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله التحيه لك ولضيوفك الكرام وللمشاهدة
لم يدعو الى الوحده
ولكن ذكر ان هنالك بعض القوى الدوليه التي
سعدت في الفتره السابقه سعي شديد جدا من
اجل فصل جنوب السودان تحدثت الان بعد ان
رات المعطيات على الواقع ان هذا القرار
كان قرارا غير سليما واعتذروا عن دفعهم
لانفصال جنوب السودان وبعض القوى الجنوبيه
وبعض القوى الاقليميه يعني حقيقه تح حسرت
على الوحده والرئيس ذكر ان هذا القرار
يعني اذا كان سعينا اليه سيتم استفتاء
لاهل شمال
السودان سي
عل مع فقط معذره فقط بعض الذين علقوا على
كلام الرئيس السوداني قال قالوا انه تحدث
عن كلام مبني للمجهول لا نعرف بالضبط من
هي هذه الاطراف التي يتحدث
عنها
الرئيس بحكم منصبه يعني يطلع على كثير جدا
من الاراء من قوه دوليه مختلفه الرئيس لا
يتحدث ويلقي الحديث عن عواهن انما يتحدث
عن حقائق صحيح قد لا يكون من المناسب
الحديث بالمعلومات كافيه ولكن هذه معلومات
توفرت للرئيس وقالها في اطار ان هذا
القرار هذه القوه الدوليه التي سعت اليه
يعني علمت انها كانت في الاتجاه الخطا من
التاريخ في دعوتها لانفصال جنوب
السودان ذلك هذا الكلام مع ذلك سيد يعني
بعد اذنك هذا الكلام قوبل
باستغراب على الاقل رسميا من دوله جنوب
السودان وهنا نسال السيد مارتن اييا من
جبا هذا الكلام اعتبر مدهش واعتبر من رابع
المستحيلات على حد تعبير بعض المسؤولين
كيف
تفهمونه
اولا نشكر الجزيره في هذا اللقاء
الهام الذي سمعنا من الاخوه في دوله
السودان كلمه البشير زي ما قرينا في
الجرائد كان بيخاطب الرعاع
والمزارعين لا نفهم انه البشير كان بيعمل
حاجتين اثنين اولا هو بيجازف من داخله
عشان يستخدم المشاكل في جنوب السودان يحل
مشاكله في السودان نفسها من اثنين هو داير
يقول الكلام ده عشان يخاطب الجنجويد
والرعا المصريه عشان يحارب جنوب السودان
زي ما شفناهم في ولا الوح وده كلام
سياسي بشير بالتقديم عشان يهل مشاكل
الداخليه وعشان نشجع الرعاء
والمزارعين السودان انه نحنا استغلينا من
يد البشير هو
طرف جنوب السودان نفسه وهو عارف انه لو
اذا كان دوله اصبح دوله حر لا يمكن عشان
واحداني اي دوله انيه يتحدث ان يتوحد بها
ونز يتجزا من الامم المتحده ولو كان هذا
الموضوع
ممكن نشيله باهميه بنطلب برضو ان السودان
يتوحد مصر العربيه لان السودان اساسا
تلقى حريته في مصر وده كلام يعني كلام
سياسي البشير على كل الموضوع عندما طرح
سيد بعد اذنك سيد اي عندما طرح الموضوع
وون نسال سيد خالد التجاني عندما طرح هذا
الموضوع الان نحن امام كلام غير واضح
المعالم من
الرئيس البشير
وكلام مستغرب ومتحفظ من مسؤولين في دوله
جنوب السودان كيف يمكن فهم هذا التباين في
موضوع
المطروح في تقديري يعني يمكن قراءه
تصريحات الرئيس البشير في سياقين في سياق
التطورات الراهنه الان الحرب الاهليه في
جنوب السودان وانعكاساتها على السودان
وكذلك في سياق التتابعات والتداعيات
التاريخيه لعمليه تقسيم السودان الاشاره
الان الى هذا النوع من التبادل الاتهامات
او هذا الجدل يشير ايضا الى ان العلاقات
بين الخرطوم وجوبه عادت مره اخرى الى مربع
التوتر بعدما كانت على وشك ان تدور عجله
التطبيع في اواخر العام الماضي ولكن الحرب
الاهليه جاءت فقطعت الطريق على ذلك المسار
وبالتالي ترتبت عليه يعني اثار اقتصاديه
وامنيه سالبه على الحكوم السوداني وكذلك
حصلت عمليه اعاده اسطاف استفاف الان هناك
نوع من التحالف لحكومه جبا مع الخصوم
السوداني الاستراتيجي مع الرئيس اليوغندي
سفني وكذلك مع الجبهه الثوريه التي كان من
المفترض ان يؤدي تطبيع العلاقات الى وقف
الدعب جبهه لها وبالتالي في تقدير ان حديث
الرئيس البشير الان اتسم بقدر ربما من
الاحساس بالخذلان او المراره الى ان يعني
عمليه فصل جنوب السودان او تقسيم البلاد
لم تاتي بالسلام الذي كان مرجو وكذلك لم
تحقق الاستقرار لا في شمال السودان ولا
كذلك في
جنوبه ايضا الكلام فهم وانا اسال السيد
كمال حسن علي الكلام فهم من الرئيس البشير
وكانه انذار مبطن لاقليم دارفور انظروا
ماذا حدث لجنوب السودان حتى لا تصبحوا على
ما فعلتم نادمين هل يمكن ايضا فهم الكلام
من هذه
الزاويه انا انا افتكر انه ليس بهذه يعني
الرئيس لو اراد ان يوجه خطابا
لاي جهه سيوجهه مباشره يعني ولكن هذا
الحديث ليس موجها للجنوب هذا الحديث موجها
للقوه التي دع هذا الانفصال لانه حقيقه
نحن احترمنا قرار الاخوه في جنوب السودان
وما زلنا نحترم خياراتهم ونقول ان الاشواق
الوحده ليست عيب اذا جاءت من الشمال او
اذا جاءت من الجنوب ولكن هذا الحديث موجه
للقوى التي وقفت خلف هذا الانفصال محاوله
لضعاف السودان والشمال على وجه الخصوص هذه
القوه كانت تراهن ان هذا الانفصال سيؤدي
الى اضعاف الشمال والى قوه الجنوب الحدث
ان الجنوب النوب يعني حدث ما فيه من احداث
نراها الان ونتابعها نحن نامل ان يعود
الجنوب الى الاستقرار نامل ان يعود الاخوه
في جنوب السودان الى الى السلم لانه حقيقه
هذا الوضع الذي يعيشه الجنوب سينعكس
غضا سلبا على الشمال فالحديث ليس موجها
الى الاخوه في جنوب السودان وانما موجه
للقوه التي دعمت هذا الانفصال هذه القوه
هذه القوه التي تشير اليها سيد علي يعني
معذره نعم معذره هذه القوه التي تشير
اليها نريد ان نسال سيد مارتن ايليا اما
اذا كان لديهم في دوله جنوب السودان احساس
ربما ربما بان فعلا الدول التي وقفت معكم
وازر تكم قد تكون تشعر الان بخيبه امل من
الوضع الداخلي في دوله جنوب السودان ومن
الاداء السياسي فقد تكون فعلا بدات تفكر
فيما قاله
البشير
ابدا مافيش اي دوله مندول الموجوده عالميا
بكلم عن ان وحده جنوب وشمال ده عباره عن
السودان نفسها بشخصيه رئيس البشير بيعبر
شعوره وعشان برض يبرر موقفه وفه مع التمرد
ووقف هو واقف مع التمرد و يكون اخر واحد
اتكلم عن عن مشاكل داخليه هو عنده
النوبه الجبال وعنده تمرد في في دارفور
وانده تمرد احزاب في خرطوم سودان ده يكون
اخر دوله اتكلم وهي عالمه اساسا انه في
تمرد في افريقيا في اماكن كثيره جدا ونحنا
لينا سنتين هم دخلوا لانه الخوارج
المتمردين قال لهم احنا لو خرجنا حكومه
سالف كير م ياجد اح واحد الجنوب مع الشمال
نديكم 50% من دخل النقود بنسلم لكم ابيع
اذا كان المصر والجنجويد معان في اخراء
حكومه س البكير ده حلم من البشير ونحنا
كنا عندنا احترام عاليه جدا للاخ البشير
لان هو سعدنا
واول رئيس في
السودان ادانا حريتنا فنحنا بنحترم ونستمر
احترم واض واضح واضح بان مثل ما قال السيد
خالد التيجاني واضح بان اجواء الشك الخلاف
ادبت من جديد بين دوله السودان وجنوب
السودان سيد خالد
تيجاني اشرت في سؤالي للسيد علي فيما
يتعلق بما اذا كان ما قاله الرئيس هو
اشاره اشاره تحذير مبطنه لدارفور
اكرر نفس السؤال عليك هل تعتقد فعلا بان
الرساله موجهه اكثر ل دارفور جنوب كردفان
النيل الازرق اكثر مما هي موجهه لدوله
جنوب
السودان
ربما لا تكون موجهه بصوره مباشره باعتبار
ان الوضع في المنطقتين يعني سواء في
دارفور او جنوب كردفان الازرق لم يصل الى
مدى
المطالبه الانفصال وان كان هناك بعض
الاشارات الغمض والحدث عن تقرير مصير ولكن
في مجمل الاشياء في مجمل الاحوال يعني
حديث الرئيس الان عندما يلغي بلائه في
تقسيم السودان على جهات اجنبيه ننسى ان
هذا التقسيم تم باتفاقيه سلام كانت
الحكومه السودانيه طرف اساسي فيها
وبالتالي يبقى يبقى السؤال يعني كيف يعني
تريد الحكومه السودانيه ان تتحدث عن كان
التقسيم تم باراده خارجيه ولم يتم في اطار
عمليه سلام كانت الحكومه السودانيه ن
نفسها طرف فيها الرئيس السوداني نفسه كان
يتحدث عن ان الانفصال بسلام خير من الوحده
مع الحرب وبالتالي يعني في تقديري ان
الحكومه السودانيه ربما الان هي تستشعر
انها بانفصال او بفصل جنوب السودان لم
يتحقق لها مصالح التي كانت ترجوها من ان
يتحقق السلام حتى الرئيس البشير نفسه كان
يحذر دائما من السيناريو الاسو هو ما يقول
ان يفقد السودان وحدته وفي نفس الوقت لا
يتحقق فيه السلام وهذا الان ما يحدث انه
تم فصل الجنوب السودان تم اعاده انتاج
الحرب في شمال وفي جنوب السودان وبالتالي
يعني بعد تمت اعاده انتاج الازمه في
البلدين وبالتالي في تقديرا المسؤوليه
بالدرجه الاولى هي مسؤوليه الطرفين
المؤتمر الوطني في شمال السودان والحركه
الشعبيه في جنوب السودان في انهما هربا
الى التقسيم بدلا من القيام باستحقاقات
عمليه السلام التي كان تتطلب عمليه تحول
ديمقراطي حقيقي تتحقق فوق كل مصالح الشعب
السوداني في مختلف ارجاء البلاد نعم اذا
اعاده اجواء انتاج الحرب او اعاده انتاج
اجواء الحرب والازمه يحيلنا بعد الفاصل ل
تعميق النقاش في السياق العام الذي تاتي
فيه هذه التصريحات سواء من الخرطوم او من
جبه لنا عوده بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها التصريحات
المتضاربه بين جبا والخرطوم فيما يتعلق
بالحديث عن الوحده بين دولتي السودان
وجنوب السودان سيد كمال حسن علي في
الخرطوم بعض المراقبين اشاروا الى ان ان
كانت هناك اتصالات من دوله جنوب السودان
بالخرطوم لاعاده احياء الوحده فبالتاكيد
هي من
بين اصوات للجنوبيين كانوا في حزب الرئيس
البشير او حتى من رياك مشار الذي هو في
خلافه الان مع ايه الحكام في في جبا هل
يمكن ان يكون هذا الكلام
صحيح هو صحيح الان هنالك بعض القوى في
جنوب السودان يعني شعرت ان الانفصال ادى
الى يعني حاله ماساويه في الجنوب من خلال
الصراع حول السلطه يعني السودان تعامل
بمسؤوليه مع ما يدور في جنوب السودان وهذا
بشهاده الجميع بشهاده ال
المتصارعين في جنوب السودان انفسهم بشهاده
المجتمع الدولي الذي يعني تحدث عن ان موقف
السودان موقف مسؤول وقف بعيدا عن هذا
الصراع ولم يسعى الى تجيره الى مصلحه
السودان وانما سعى عبر الوساطه وساطه
الافريقيه عبر الايجاد الى ان يصلح بين
الفرقاء في جنوب السودان بعض الاخوه
الجنوبيين شعروا ان قرار الانفصال ادى الى
هذا الواقع وبالتالي يعني عندهم احلام الى
الوحده لانه في ظل الوحده كان الوضع افضل
كثيرا مما كان عليه الحال الان هذا كما
قلت هذه الاحلام اذا كانت من اخوه في
الجنوب او اخوه في الشمال احلام مشروعه ان
تكون هنالك وحده ولكن موقفنا الرسمي هو
احترامنا لقرار الاخوه في جنوب السودان
والسودان والرئيس البشير هو الذي يعني اصر
على قيام الاستفتاء والالتزام باتفاقيه
نفاش وبالتالي انا افتكر انه الحديث
الدائر الان ليس دعوه للوحده وانما ليذكر
الذين سعوا للانفصال لانه كما قلت ان
اتفاقيه النفاشه كانت تدعو الطرفين ان
يعمل الطرفان من اجل الوحده ا في هذه
الحاله ا هذه الحاله الب اذا في هذه
الحاله معذره مره اخرى في هذه الحاله هل
يمكن القول وهنا اسال السيد مارتن اليا هل
يمكن القول
بان الضعف العام في الدوله الحديثه في
جنوب
السودان مع وجود تناقضات داخل الحكم نفسه
اعطى الفرصه للخرطوم كي تلعب على هذه
التناقضات هل يمكن فهم ما جرى ضمن هذا
السياق سيد مارتن ايليا
الو هل تسمع اسمع اولا ا اقول اسمع الان
اسمع ا اوضح اولا ان جنوب السودان اصبح
دوره متقل واي وهم اي تفكير انه تحصل وحده
بين الشمال بين الجنوب السودان ده حلم لا
ينجز و ناكد لك انه جنوب السودان مستقره
اكثر من دوله السودان السودان لها تمرد من
كل الجهات ويمكن دارفور تفصل يمكن جبل
تنفصل وتبقى جزء من من جنوب السودان نحن
ننفي بتاتا اي حلم اذا كان في حلم حلم من
المتمردين لانهم دايرين دعم عسكري من دينه
السودان زي ما شفناه في الوحده جابوا
تجاويد وجابوا نعم ولكن سيد ايي يعني اكرر
سؤالي اكرر سؤالي بعد اذنك هل اكرر سؤالي
بغض النظر حلم او وهم هل كانت لديكم
تناقضات استطاع البشير ان يستفيد منها
وربما هذا مشروع في العلاقه المتوتره بين
الخرطوم
وجب اكيد بشير لها استفاده كبيره جدا نا
هسه عندنا قروش لبشير من البنزين بسموها
ترشم ده مبلغ كميه هائله من طيبه جنوب
السودان طيبه رئيس جنوب السودان لحكومه
السودان لان حكومه السودان بدون دعم
السودان ما بتقله الدوله فنحنا بنطلب شير
ترجع الاتفاق بتاعنا اتفاق التعامل ننفذها
بدل يتعامل مع الخوارج ويخاطب رعاء وخاتم
مزعين وهم ديول هم اللي
بيكونوا القوه اللي بيستخدموها جنجويد
يمشي يحاربنا في
الوحده ياثر في انتاج النفط ده سياسه من
البشير وحكومته فقط وما في دوله لها يعني
دوله جزء من من الامم المتحده
تطلب دوله ثانيه عشان تواحد مع جنوب
السودان اذا في هذه الحاله اذا في هذه
الحاله سي يعني معذره في هذه الحاله سيد
خالد تيجاني هل
يمكن فهم ما قاله الرئيس
البشير على انه
ربما نوع من استفزاز الوضع الداخلي في
جنوب السودان ومحاوله التاثير على الراي
العام الداخلي الذي صوت بنسبه 99% مع
الانفصال ربما يعني هذا صحيح ان الرئيس
البشير يحاول الان ان يشير الى ان انفصال
الجنوب هو السبب في ما يحدث الان لمواطني
جنوب السودان ولكن في تقدير ايضا من جهه
اخرى يضيف ايضا الى ان الان السودان
مصالحه الحيويه حقيقه تتضرر بفعل هذه
الحرب وفي نفس الوقت الذي تبدو فيه
السودان في يذ اوراق محدوده للغايه الان
المتحرك الاكبر في جنوب السودان هي اوغندا
هي خصم استراتيجي بالنسبه للخرطوم وكذلك
الجبهه الثوريه التي ايضا تقاتل الخرطوم
فبالتالي الان الحكومه السودانيه بين
حقيقه خياراتها محدوده هي كانت مصطفى في
الى جانب الرئيس الفكير في اطار موقف
ايجاد الان موقف ايجاد هذا يعني غير قادر
على تغيير المعادله على الارض هناك اعاده
ترتيب لتحالفات على الارض ربما هذا يفضي
ربما كان هو تمهيد حقيقه لاعاده تحالفات
بالنسبه للخرطوم سابقا مع يعني قوى جنوبيه
كانت معلومه بالذات في مناطق وير او معروف
كذلك ان رياك مشار كان اول من وقع اتفاق
سلام مع الخرطوم في العام 97 وبالتالي
الان ربما في تقدير الخرطوم تحاول تمهيد
لاعاده ترتيب اوراقها واعاده حساباتها
وربما اعاده تحالفاتها في الساحه الجنوبيه
وهل تعتقد سيد تجاني بان هذا الكلام
الفجئه الان عن الوحده قد يستمر في الفتره
المقبله نعم هل هل بتقديرك سيستمر هذا
الحديث عن الوحده
عفوا
واضح انك لم تسمع اطرح هذا السؤال نف في
تقديري يعني هذا الحديث تفضل افضل افضل في
تقديري في تقديري هذا الحديث في تقديري
هذا الحديث جاء عرضا موضوع الوحده وصير
عرضا في اطار صياغ طورات الراهنه ولكنه
حقيقه ليس مقصودا لذاته ولكن هو اشاره
للتبعات والتطورات الحاصله الان في الساحه
ولكن لا ليس وارد على الاقل في اطار
النظامين الموجودين حاليا في الخرطوم وفي
جب نعم سؤال اخير لضيفنا في جب وفي
الخرطوم باختصار شديد سيد كمال حسن علي هل
تعتقد بان هذا الحديث الذي جاء عرضا سيذهب
ايضا
عرضا يعني انا اولا احب ان اصحح معلومات
يعني الحديث عن انه السودان دعم القوات
المتمردين في في جنوب السودان حديث غير
صحيح ارجو يعني من الاخ في جنوب الس هو
دائما على كل هو دائما الخرطوم تنفي
الخرطوم تنفي دعم
المتمردين في دعم المتمردين هذه قضيه
طويله لنبقى في سؤالي لو
تكرمت
ها هذه حقيقه انا كما قلت لك الرئيس الان
عندما دع يعني قال هذا الحديث لم يقل انه
يريد الوحده الان مع جنوب السودان انما
قال ان القوه التي دعمت انفصال الجنوب
يعني ندمت واعتذرت عن هذا الفعل الذي
فعلته وسعت الان ويعني دعت الى وحده
السودان مع جنوب السودان ولم يقل نحن نريد
يعني الوحده مع جنوب السودان وقال ان
الجنوب اذا راينا ان هنالك مشروع للوحده
مع الجنوب يجب ان يستفتح شعب شمال السودان
في هذا الامر وانا افتكر انه ده يؤكد اننا
نحترم خيار الاخوه في جنوب السودان اننا
يعني دعمنا قيام هذه الدوله ونرجو ونامل
لها الاستقرار حتى انه يعيش البلدان في
امن واستقرار نعم سيد مارتن اليا هل هل
تتوقع ان يستمر هذا الحديث في الفتره
المقبله هو حديث باطل طبعا
و ودي نهايته نهايته جرائد فقط ولكن احنا
بنطلب من البشير انه الرئيس القير له
احترام له
وله يعني شد بيه ك دايرين انه يستمروا في
علاقاتهم المعروفه او زياراتهم المتبادله
حتى
ان ش شكرا شكرا لك سيد شكرا لك سيد
شكرا لك سيد مارتن كان بودنا ان نستمع الى
الى جوابك للنهايه ولكن اهتزاز الصوت يحول
دون فهم حتى ما تقوله شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
مارتن ايليا وزير شؤون الرئاسه في دوله
جنوب السودان كنت معنا من جب شكرا لضيفنا
من الخرطوم كمال حسن علي وزير الدوله
لشؤون الرعايه الاجتماعيه وايضا ضيفنا
خالد التيجاني رئيس تحرير صحيفه الف بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه في امان
الله
ت